So we're on problem number one
on the California Standards
Test Problems for Algebra II.
And so the theory being is if
you're able to do all or at
least understand all 80 of these
questions, I think you
have a pretty good understanding
of Algebra II,
at least from the perspective
of California.
Let's see, problem number one.
What is the complete solution
to the equation the absolute
value of 3 minus 6x
is equal to 15?
So let's think about it.
3 minus 6x could clearly be 15,
because the absolute value
of 15 is 15.
So we could say that 3
-- sorry that's a 3.
3 minus 6x could
be equal to 15.
But 3 minus 6x could also be
equal to minus 15, right?
Because the absolute value
of minus 15 is also 15.
So let's write that down.
Or 3 minus 6x is equal
to minus 15, right?
If this was equal to minus 15,
you'd take the absolute value,
you'd get positive 15.
So either of these
could be true.
So let's solve for x.
Subtract 3 from both sides,
you get minus
6x is equal to 12.
Divide both sides by minus 6,
you get x is equal to minus 2.
And so here, if we subtract 3
from both sides, you get minus
6x is equal to minus
15 minus 3.
That's minus 18.
Divide both sides my minus
6, you get x is equal
to positive 3, right?
A negative divided by a negative
, so x is equal to 3.
So x could be minus 2 or
3, and that's choice b.
Problem two.
Let me switch colors to make
things interesting.
And this is a similar
type of problem.
What are the possible values of
x in the absolute value of
12 minus 4x is equal to 2?
Same logic.
12 minus 4x could be 2, right?
The absolute value of 2 is 2.
So you you get 12 minus
4x is equal to 2.
Or 12 minus 4x could
be minus 2, right?
Because the absolute value
of minus 2 is 2.
So then you get 12 minus 4x
could be equal to minus 2.
So this is an or proposition.
So let's see, subtract 12 from
both sides, you get minus 4x.
2 minus 12 is minus 10.
Then you get x.
Divide both sides by minus 4
is minus 10 over minus 4.
The negatives cancel out.
And that's equal to 5/2,
or 2 and 1/2, for 2.5.
And the only reason I wrote 2.5
is I was looking at the
choices, and they have
everything as decimals.
So let's look at the other
possibilities.
Subtract 12 from both sides, you
get minus 4x is equal to
minus 2 minus 12 is minus 14.
x is equal to minus
14 over minus 4.
Negatives cancel out, which is
equal to 7/2, which is equal
to 3 and 1/2, which
is equal to 3.5.
So x could be 2.5 or 3.5,
and that is choice d.
Problem three.
I'll switch to maybe green.
For weddings, Sherada bought
several dozen roses and
several dozen carnations.
The roses cost $15 per dozen,
so roses are $15 per dozen,
the carnations cost $8 per
dozen, so the carnations are
$8 per dozen.
Sherada bought a total of
17 dozen flowers and
paid a total $192.
How many roses did she buy?
All right, so let's set
some variables.
Let R equal dozens of roses.
I hope you can read
my handwriting.
And let C equal to dozens
of carnations.
All right, so they say
that she bought a
total of 17 dozen flowers.
So the dozens of roses she
bought plus the dozens of
carnations she bought must be
equal to 17 because she bought
a total of 17 dozens.
It also tells us that
she spent $192.
So how do we figure out how
much money she spent?
So if she bought R dozens
of roses, how much did
she spend on roses?
Well, each dozen of
roses is $15.
So she spent 15 times the
number of dozens.
That's how much she
spent on roses.
How much did she spend
on carnations?
Well, she bought C dozens
of carnations.
Each dozen was $8.
She spent 8C dollars
on carnations.
So her total amount of money she
spent was the amount she
spent on roses plus the amount
she spent on carnations, and
that is equal to 192.
Now, we have two linear
equations and two unknowns.
We can just solve them.
We want to solve for the
number of roses.
That was the question.
So let's try to cancel out
the number of carnations.
So if we multiply this top
equation by minus 8, we'll get
a minus 8C.
That'll cancel out with that,
so let's do that.
So let's multiply that top
equation by minus 8.
You get minus 8R minus 8C.
What's minus 8 times 17?
Let's see, 17-- I'll do it in
the corner here-- 17 times 8,
7 times 8 is 56, 1 times 8 is
13, plus 5 is 1, 1 times-- oh,
my brain was getting
ahead of me.
1 times 8 is 8, plus 5 is 13.
Sorry.
It's equal to 136.
Oh, and we would multiply it by
negative 8, so we'd put a
negative there.
And now we can add these
two equations.
15 minus 8, 7R.
8C minus 8C is 0-- and that
was the whole point behind
multiplying this top equation
by minus 8-- is equal
to 192 minus 36.
Let's see.
We can do little borrowing, or
regrouping, they call it now.
That's 12, that's 8,
so it equals 56.
7R is equal to 56, so
R is equal to 8.
So Sherada bought 8 dozens of
roses, and that is choice C.
Problem four.
What is the solution
to the system of
equations shown below?
And there's three of them with
three variables, always the
hairiest problem.
Let's see.
We have 2x minus y plus
3z is equal to 8.
We have x minus 6y minus
z is equal to 0.
And then you get minus 6x plus
3y minus 9z is equal to 24.
Now there's a bunch of
ways to solve these.
You could use matrices and
inverses of matrices and
Gauss-Jordan elimination, or you
can just kind of use your
traditional multiplying
equations by each other and
adding them so that you can kind
of constrain them or take
out variables.
And we'll do the last one
because I don't want to
introduce any other kind of
matrix manipulation here.
So what I want to do is, let's
use this equation with both of
these, and try to cancel
out the x's, right?
Well, let's think of how
we could do that.
Well, one thing I like to do,
just to simplify it, is to get
all of the equations in what I
consider lowest integer from.
I know that's not
a formal term.
But look at all the terms
in this equation.
They're all divisible
by 3, right?
So let's divide all
of them by 3.
So this last equation would
become-- if you divide
everything by 3, you'd get minus
2x plus y minus 3z is
equal to 8.
So let's cancel that out.
I just divided it by 3.
It's the same thing.
Remember, whatever you do to
one side of an equation you
can do to the other side
of the equation.
Anyway, so let's use this
equation and this equation and
then this equation and this
equation to get two equations
with just y's and z's.
So essentially we want to
cancel out the x's.
So to cancel out the x's with
this one and this one, we can
just add them, right?
Because 2x plus minus
2x, that's going to
cancel out the x's.
So we can just do that.
And then when we do it with
this equation, we could
multiply this equation times
minus 2 first and it'll cancel
out the x's there.
So let's do it.
So let's just write it and
I'll write it in green.
So if I add this equation to
this equation, 2x minus 2x is
0x minus y plus y, that's 0y.
These are all zero, but I'm just
writing them down to show
that we're done.
Well, they all cancel out.
Plus 0z.
These are equal to 8 plus
8 is equal to 16.
So you get 0 is equal to 16,
which makes no sense.
So there's actually
no solution here.
And if you wanted to think
about visually what's
happening is each of these
equations represents a plane
in three dimensions.
And the only way you get no
solution or no intersection
between this equation and this
equation or this equation,
which are essentially the same
equation, the only reason why
you can't get the intersection
between them is that they must
be parallel equations.
You could get an infinite number
of solutions if they
were actually the same plane.
But these are parallel planes,
so they'll never intersect.
So we saw.
And it kind of makes sense
because this part-- well, I'm
not going to go into
the details.
We're just focused on solving
problems right now.
But it's fair enough to say
that when you add this
equation to this equation to
cancel out the x's, everything
else cancels out and you got
a nonsensical statement, 0
equals 16, so there's no
solution and that's choice c.
And those are parallel planes
in three dimensions.
Problem five.
A restaurant manager bought
20 packages of bagels.
Some packages contained 6
bagels each and the rest
contain 12 bagels each.
There were a 168
bagels in all.
How many packets of 12 bagels
did the manager buy?
So he bought some
packages of 6.
So the packages of 6 plus the
packages of 12, that's just my
random notation that
I invented.
He bought a total of 20
packages, so that equals 20,
and he bought a total of
168 bagels in all.
So how many bagels did he
get from the 6-packs?
Well, each of them had
6 bagels, right?
So he got 6 times the
number of packs.
So he got 6 times this.
This is the number of bagels he
got from the 6-packs, and
then this is the number
bagels he got from
the 12-packs, right?
The number of packs times 12,
and then that is equal to 168.
Two equations, two unknowns.
They're linear equations.
We should be able
to solve this.
So they want to know how
many packages of the 12
bagels did he buy?
So they want to know what p sub
12, or whatever you want
to call that is.
So if we want to do that, let's
cancel out the P6's.
So if we multiply that top
equation by minus 6, you get
minus 6 times the 6-packs, minus
6 times the 12-packs--
I'm just multiplying this top
thing by minus 6-- is
equal to minus 120.
Now, we can add the
two equations.
These cancel out.
That was the whole point.
12 times the 12-packs minus 6
times the 12-packs, that's
equal to 6 times the 12-packs.
It's equal to 168
minus 120 is 48.
And so we get the 12-packs,
there were 48
divided by 6 is 8.
So there were 8 12-packs.
The manager bought 8 12-packs.
That is choice b.
And I'll see you in the
next video because
I'm all out of time.